- Le chantier est énorme
et occupé.
une rivière d'un kilomètre",
explique une des responsablesss
du projet. Elle sera entourée
de parcs, de marais et de terres
humides restaurées.
déverser dans le lac Ontario
plus facilement au
déborder vers les quartiers
résidentiels", dit Shannon
Baker. Lorsqu'elle
le projet protégera 240 ha
l'équivalent d'un quartier
s'étendrait de la tour CN
jusqu'au centre Eaton,
et ce à 20 minutes de marche
du centre-ville.
C'est ce que cet expert appelle
le de classe mondiale
d'adaptation au changement
climatique. "Les Port Lands
toujours été vulnérables
aux inondations, et ce risqueau,
dit-il.
"Le climat devient plus chaud,.
Et pas seulement à Toronto.
Même dans les scénarios
plus optimistes, les experts
climatiques prévoient que dans
les jours de chaleur extrême
sera deux fois plus fréquents
au cours des 30 prochaines
années qu'ils ne l'étaient
entre 1976 et 2005.
Les villes sont-elles prêtes
pour ces changements?
prêts pour ce qui se passe
maintenant", répond l'expert.
Fiona vient de ravager l'est
du pays. À l'ouest de l'an
dernier, Colombie-Britanniqu
la plus meurtriè
son histoire, suivie
des inondations les plus
coûteuses. L'insta prévoit que i
2025, la moitié de la croissance
du PIB du pays
s'envoleatique.atique.atique.at.
JULIEN BOURQUE, associé à la
rech., Inst. climatique du Can.
- Si on r exemple,
qu'ils ont une politique
tion nationale depuis
10 ans maintenant alors queproc,
je dirais qu'on est pas
nécessairement en avance...
- Ottawa a promis de publier
sa première stratnale
d'ici janvier. Les experts
espèrent qu'elle sera vite mise
en oeuvrlles elle
nous prépare sont déjà en cours.
Radio-Canada, Tor